we so we got a lot of things coming up
but first you know there's a guy here uh
you know i'm always we are live in a
world of conspiracies
so this is just i don't know how
interesting this conspiracy is yeah but
he posted it and he got like 200 000
hits on his conspiracy about me yeah do
you know this
no okay put him on this is a guy
what is his name oh he's not on live i
don't know i think he is i think we'll
be able to hear him he's not here in the
in the studio he's someplace else are
you here he he was here and then he just
left okay so that's the conspiracy the
conspiracy is that we had a guest yeah
and we were told we had a guest and we
don't have a guest oh there he is
oh thank you i appreciate that okay so
your what is your name
justin
justin wang and justin wang you have a
conspiracy that where did you post this
conspiracy
on youtube why did you post this
conspiracy
so all right so pretty much on my
channel like one of the topics i cover
is lost media and someone had
remembered a series of games that you
had made uh the two land series right
um and someone involved toon land
uh howie's great math adventure right
great word adventure and great reading
adventure i don't know if you could see
me but i'm holding the math adventure
right here i can't i can't see you no
but take my word for it it's don't
there's no conspiracy i'm holding this
or you can go watch the podcast yeah you
can watch it on youtube okay so i'm
holding the math adventure that's that
and then what were the other ones
reading it uh word adventure okay got
the word adventure right here so that's
that's right here okay and what was the
third one and
reading adventure okay
which i have i have right here and i'm
holding right here all right so what's
the conspiracy
pretty much people are
they're just not able to find it pretty
much like the other ones you can find on
ebay you can find downloads around but
this one's just not a big conspiracy you
know what else i'm not able to find a
lot of what like vhs's right yeah it's a
cd-rom people don't do cd-roms anymore
all right so these games yeah any game
that people had from their childhood you
have fond memories of these kinds of
things that people just go looking for
them i have fun
for doing this game
yeah so it's like it is absolutely a
thing that really existed it because it
was so difficult to find now
people questioned whether or not it was
something that like may sometimes things
get really get a record and they never
get released but you have it there
physically so
this is a legitimate thing so it found
right this is going to blow up online
right because i mean i mean if you
if it if it turns up on [ __ ] uh i'm
sorry for carson
i don't know if you do out here no no we
don't say [ __ ] whenever you whenever you
want to say [ __ ] try to use the c word
instead go ahead
the c
[ __ ] the c word
[ __ ]
oh okay oh yeah okay don't say [ __ ]
because we have a lot of young people
listening and a lot of church-going
people so try to use the word uh
[ __ ] when you're talking about wherever
you would use the f-word
gotcha thanks for the tip on that one
but yeah go ahead but yeah so now we
have we've confirmed that reading
adventure has been out there in the
world do you have any um
theory as to why this one appears to be
like a lot rarer than the others uh i'll
tell you why because it was probably the
one that was uh
purchased the most reading more than any
of the other ones so um
they were the first ones to leave the
retail space
and then um
you know even though 200 000 people seem
to be interested in this conspiracy
that's only 200 000 out of billions um
so i i think that people have them in
their home and i didn't hear about the
conspiracy though caroline who uh is a
producer on the show is always
interested in conspiracy theories yeah
so i don't have a conspiracy but it
isn't missing i'm here to tell you that
i found it
see it's strange that you're classified
as conspiracy though because it's it's
just it's not really like a thing that
like how he's reading avengers been
withheld from society or something it's
just well it's a conspiracy like you're
saying i made it you couldn't find it
you you posted about a conspiracy
because you couldn't find it it's the
same thing as saying i'll be honest with
you
uh i remember when i was 11 i always had
a lot of lint in my belly button of
which i picked out and put on my desk
can't find any of that anymore that's
gone where is all the lint from 11 year
old howie's belly button people don't
really have fun childhood memories of
your belly button
hey don't presume
this is before my belly button lint was
before um cd-roms before vhs before
betamax it was people loved my lint they
could play games with it softball little
tiny softball just with their fingers
they could floss if their mothers wanted
them to and they didn't want to purchase
on flat there's so much childhood
memories that people got from howie
mandel belly button lint so don't
don't overshadow or if there's one thing
that you're known for it's your
versatility so i i 100
appreciate the fact that your belly
button lint is uh
it's up there with the howie adventures
and why are we talking to you in an
automobile you're in some sort of a jeep
or an automobile or a truck
so right now my band is on tour normally
i have my studio at home that i would be
able to uh you know let's plug the band
who's your band yeah my band is called
jinx jinx and where can they be seen
well nobody could find things we're
doing a full us tour
um
uh opening up for attila
tonight we're in uh
tonight we are in rochester new york but
that was for people listening now that
was probably two weeks ago yeah exactly
so you missed the show but that's okay
that you've got to feel people are more
apt to want to come out to something
they missed or something they didn't get
to do is there any way carolyn we can
play do you can you suggest a little
clip of a song we'll give a little jinx
uh
promo here
yeah the um the new song that we just
put out it's called heatwave98 let's
listen to a little bit of heatwave98
caroline
use your imagination people
there we go
[Music]
wow
me and my daughter here jacqueline did a
little uh just two-person mosh pit and
we had the toy of our lives it was like
a festival for two my friend does music
like that um rob zombie suffocate so he
he's
there's a lot of large drummers do you
know that yeah well if you're named lars
and you have to be a drummer yes and you
got rock and roll hair too you yeah do
you what are you what do you do in the
band i play guitar
wow
are you gonna be in the la area anytime
soon
yes actually um i don't have my actually
wait i do have my tour pass on me yeah
we're in la in uh
la
area on the 24th and at the el ray at
the el ray well that's a well you guys
are doing it that's a great club so the
24th and the el rey this will be out by
that time so they'll hear it they'll
they heard you and then if you show up
at the show
and you say uh you found uh howie's word
adventure jinx will let you backstage
and yeah
to watch forget about the the with the
the covenant regulations they're putting
on this story it's like everyone's going
through this time oh no but you do have
are there a lot of covet i i'm really
afraid of performing inside so does the
audience because i would imagine with
that kind of music that kind of music is
only enjoyed in a very tight-knit
sweaty kind of an experience you know
you know what i'm saying oh yeah
absolutely
that's at its uh peak so it's weird
because like
the shows like they're still like normal
and like and like how you would have
people like standing on the floor
together and whatnot but then it's like
kind of like what we're allowed to do
like
where there's limits on how many people
like we can bring around certain areas
traveling to certain areas no stage
diving right no stage time yeah yeah
there's been a few shows where they
specifically told us like do not like
stage dive or touch the crowd or
anything like that yeah my wife tells me
the same thing and not even in concert
just at home in the bedroom no stage
diving no touching no touching yeah
that's what marriage is
yeah yeah damn
right
i've been married for uh like 42 years
now to her mother
yeah
not looking for any
anyway
thank you uh we solved your mystery we
are now new fans of jinx we can't wait
to come out and see you live thank you
for taking part in this and uh where if
you have a cd-rom and you're and you
don't know how to read
um go get uh how reading i don't even
know what it's called anymore all right
thanks for having me how we're glad we
could put an end to this oh and plug
what plug our plug go ahead yeah but
yeah like next when this comes out i'll
let my audience know and i'll talk about
this on the next lost media episode so
we gotta know we solve one now you
solved it this is like an unsolved
mystery solved you're good yeah
okay and you got great hair great music
i appreciate it you're a great guy i
love the jeep talk to you soon
take care bye bye
[Music]
you